this year's edition of San Diego
comic-con was a slightly more subdued
affair than usual amidst some of the
usual hi for all things geeky both
Marvel Studios and HBO skipped the event
entirely still even with those two
powerhouses missing there was plenty to
talk about both good and bad here's a
look at the four best and for worse
reveals at San Diego comic-con 2018 best
the Shazam trailer
DC's slate of superhero films have been
criticized in the past for being too
dark and serious well it seems like
Warner Brothers was listening because
the first trailer for Shazam was an
embroidered joy full of fun and laughs
from pop-culture references to stars a
curry Levi's wide-eyed glee as a boy
stuck in a superheros body everything
about Shazam was pitch perfect making it
one of the best debuts in recent
comic-con history worst bumblebees body
generally speaking the Transformers
prequel bumblebee looks like it's
heading in the right direction with a
scaled-down story and more human size
emotional content but fans were gravely
disappointed when director Travis Knight
revealed at a comic-con panel at the
flying Decepticon in the trailer is now
fans hoped and expected it to be saying
I'm gonna break a few hearts here today
it is not Starscream instead it turns
out the bad guy is actually Blitzwing a
Decepticon who just happens to look a
lot like the fun favorite villain
Starscream it seems kind of like a mean
trick but then again should we really be
surprised at the ception from a
Decepticon best the aquaman trailer
described a Star Wars set beneath the
sea and led by a dazzling cast featuring
Jason Momoa Nicole Kidman Patrick Wilson
and Amber Heard Aquaman wasn't just one
of Warner Brothers most anticipated
reveals at this year's SDCC it was also
one of its best between the moas Aquaman
facing off with Wilson's villainous
shark riding armed to become the
rightful ruler of Atlantis and all those
breathtaking underwater set pieces the
Aquaman trailer was as The Hollywood
Reporter put it the best received at
comic-con our appetite has definitely
been wet there was worse pep talk ever
worse the James Gunn double whammy
even though Marvel Studios skipped
comic-con they still managed to make the
biggest headlines but not in a good way
on Friday July 20th the second day of
comic-con
it was announced that writer and
director
James Gunn had been fired from guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 after a conservative
website enough some controversial tweets
Gunn posted prior to landing his gig
with Marvel gonna been scheduled to
appear at Sony's Comicon panel later
that evening to announce a secret
project but in the wake of his firing
that appearance was cancelled as well
leaving the status of the project up in
the air
Gunn getting fired and then not
appearing at SDCC was a two-fold shocker
one Twitter user best summed up it's
crazy that the only thing the MCU
brought to Comic Con this year was a
firing of James Gunn best the glass
trailer nearly two decades after his
2000 hit and breakable director M night
Shyamalan finally unveiled the trailer
for the long-awaited sequel glass which
also acts as a follow-up to 2017 split
stylish wonderfully self-aware sprinkled
with action and featuring Sarah Paulsen
as a psychiatrist who specializes in
treating super-powered people glass
looks to be an ambitious return to form
we can't wait to see how it all turns
out worse the Johnny Depp debacle after
unleashing a magical trailer for
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald Warner Brothers gave
comic-con a rollicking good time with a
panel featuring stars Jude Law and Ezra
Miller unfortunately those good times
turned a little sour when embattled
actor Johnny Depp showed up in full
costume as the villainous Gellert
Grindelwald appearing to a very mixed
reaction of cheers & boos depp press
forward with a pre-written monologue but
for some funds the appearance was
particularly jarring given his ex-wife
Amber Heard who famously accused Depp of
domestic abuse appeared on the same
stage less than two hours later to
promote Aquaman reaction online was
particularly negative with one Twitter
user writing the fact that the audience
didn't boo Johnny Depp off the stage at
Comic Con highly disappoints me best
Star Wars the Clone Wars lives a war
left and finished until now those six
words sent attendees at this year's San
Diego Comic Con into fits of embroidered
joy as Disney and Lucasfilm announced a
return of the fan favorite animated
series Star Wars the Clone Wars which
Disney had abruptly canceled when they
acquired the rights to Star Wars way
back in 2013 now fans finally will get
their wish as Clone Wars supervising
director Dave Filoni said that the 12
episode revival which is set to debut on
Disney's upcoming new streaming service
only happened because of viewers
relentless
soozee Azzam and supports turns out
anything is truly possible with the
force worst bye bye Rick in May 20 18
fans of the wildly popular TV series of
Walking Dead were thrown for a loop and
reports began swirling that Andrew
Lincoln who plays lead Rick Grimes would
be leaving the show for good during the
show's upcoming 9th season
Lincoln however remained mum leading
some funds to hope that maybe those
reports were wrong unfortunately though
Lincoln - those hopes during his
appearance at Comic Con
telling bereaved fans that he was indeed
quitting this will be my last season
playing the part of Rick Grimes
this has been the most extraordinary
amazing and beautiful experience of my
career these guys here are the greatest
surrogate family I could have wished for
but I do have a real family and it's
time for me to go home we're not crying
you are
[Music]